I mean have you guys had a chance to
[Laughter]
like so much fun as it looked
was it cold they put you through huh
we shot like you know really late at
night things that we would like shoot
this shoot sunrise and then go back in
to shoot days what was it about this
show that made you guys go I got to do
it like I have to say yes to this
amazing
yeah the dialogue is so witty and fun
even when it gets dark it's always just
smart and
yeah quirky and the characters I mean
know what like when I started taking a
look at you when I got the audition and
just started looking at the different
things of different characters I
couldn't believe how interesting and
funny each person was and and and then
now as we've seen everybody expand it's
just like it's amazing you know and I
was really excited to take Charlene
Harris's world from the pages in the
book and bring it to real life and bring
it on camera and first of all I was
honored to be a part of that process and
second all I was like how do we get to
like create this world there's so much
opportunity in that and I was excited to
me so you want to see with your own eyes
if you can picture it right and I get to
be a part of it was just so cool it
seems like you guys bonded quickly and I
imagine it has something to do with
those midnight shoots and the cold
weather fighting Nazi bikers and demonic
entities our Creator Monika Breen she
worked so hard to capture the essence of
each character and so like for me it was
like I was excited to meet each person
and when I did meet you guys like oh my
god you're so physical changes from the
bar but I think she I think it's really
true to the essence of all these
characters yeah I love that you're a fan
girl for midnight Texas didn't know I
didn't know the books and my my
introduction to the show is a
conversation with Monica and david
janolari and explained the character and
I was like I'm in I mean it's just they
had it laid out and they do you know
they knew what they wanted and it was I
thought he was in my wheelhouse
I was like and then I started to realize
you know why is everybody staring at me
everybody's like
we also gonna mention that you're
playing a where Tiger had the
conversation with them I didn't I didn't
they didn't tell me that and then I had
a subsequent conversation was I already
signed on they go open by the way you
turn into a tiger it is the most
stunning most expensive yep tiger you'll
ever say I mean we had the best proof in
the world well it's gonna talk to you
guys about the makeup and cost me
because it's unreal it's like an amazing
bilious was that like a lot of fun for
you guys television characters I think
we mentioned you know somebody said why
is this different than anything else in
television and I'm like the special
effects on this or another level like
they really they spent a lot of money on
the show and but it's not all CGI like
we corporate CGI with the practical
props
yeah I actually turn into a tiger but
it's so great to have like actual people
actual actors lunging at you as opposed
to just a like for for us a lot of these
like scary monstrous beings really look
like what the audience is gonna see so
sometimes it was hard to look at them as
an actor that's actually scaring me okay
gonna pull it together
I mean it was really amazing so much of
this that was so realistic right and
that's I get the best stuff from you
guys go write those reactions cuz you're
actually seeing it practically yeah we
were doing such a great world to plan
I'm sorry I'm talking over you our
production design team to like we
watched them when we got to New Mexico
the town of midnight was still being
built and so we actually got to see
midnight come to life and they did an
incredible job and my apartment I'm
like I cannot believe someone created
that so I just like across the board we
had the like best casting crew that's
all set against this beautiful backdrop
of New Mexico mountains our town is on
right by a mountain range I mean it's
just beautiful
you know yeah production value of that
is that's awesome you know just
different backed up stall plot wise you
know with any new show there's
comparisons that are made but the people
who in this show are the same ones
behind shows like Chu blood so you guys
seen your resemblance between those
shows and will satisfy people's cravings
you know fans of True Blood and shows
like that yeah of course because I mean
ultimately you know Charlene harris
created the characters and so we are
another of Charlene's creations and
develop my by Monica green Monica Breen
and so what you have is a similar thread
but then in this I think there's a lot
more to a relationship can choose within
the community we're not separate rightly
together red and ya know I think Monica
made a conscious effort to kind of stay
true to the book says posta true blog
where they kind of went on their own
mm-hmm they had the characters but they
did their own thing Monica really liked
the world
Charlene created for us and just kind of
expanded on it but she was really
ensuring the bus chair yeah this show is
about a safe haven for outsiders in this
wacky town Holly would work what's your
safe haven where you guys go to you know
get some peace what's last movie you saw
by yourself ah big driver okay safe
haven all right so in midnight everyone
has a secret so I want to learn some
secrets from set are you guys ready for
this little rapid fire how long did you
spend in the hair and makeup share two
minutes yeah so as you can tell I'm
naturally blue-eyed who spent the most
time in the makeup chair but is just for
for Comic Con just for daily life anyone
had natural no I don't think any of us
really spent I think I think the
prosthetics I think those folks really
had to get like green dots on their
faces yeah but that was just like some
tape or a marker on my back I really
blew my mind all right next one is
midnight Texas a real place of course it
is did you actually shoot in Texas
[Music]
which I didn't even know was a play I
did not know you're going to real Las
Vegas for the last week of shooting the
pilot and then we found out we were
going to Las Vegas New Mexico and the
more you know you see what I did there
son NBC folks all right uh in scenes
with ghosts and spirits did on camera
did yeah last one for you what are you
like or what do you turn into at
midnight okay tonight tonight we have to
work tomorrow man you're sleeping
you